you know the stories
but what if one thing changed
everything that doesn't sound ominous at
all on
august 11th expect the unexpected
it cannot be let's be honest we've been
through weirder
and ask yourself the question what if
it appears we have a common enemy i
guess i have to freestyle then
streaming august 11th only on disney
plus
yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a
job with peace
do we know each other
time
[Music]
reality reality
[Music]
it's changeable
where you want to be
that's the question isn't it every
universe
is different each one
[Music]
slow down a little bit there's a few
people in the room that don't understand
not me i get it
who are you the name's captain carter
[Music]
i am the watcher i observe all that
transpires here
but i do not cannot will not interfere
i guess i have to freestyle then
never fly solo
i said never flies solo
is that some kind of catchphrase
you had me wear it for a second
journey to face the unknown and ponder
the question
[Music]
what if
you